did you like know about like the story
time scene or did you just kind of like
discover it as you did it i discovered
it as i did it so then that's how i
started watching like other people and i
was like well the whole community and
then
and then i initially i wasn't gonna like
get involved in the community because at
the time i was like all night friends ah
that's so juvenile it's like middle
school that's the last time i had an
online friend all right and then now
most of my friends are on like
i mean i think cause when you're when
you don't really want to interact with
circles but you become like i guess
very big in a certain community yeah
yeah you kind of almost expected to talk
to other creators in it almost weirdly
you kind of you don't mind you you
always get pressured by your audience as
well
yeah collab with this guy especially
it's everyone else
if everyone else is talking with each
other yeah you're the only one not
talking to everyone it's kind of like i
guess i should say hi
yeah but it also kind of like weirdly is
be like oh wow like does he think he's
better than the rest of us
sometimes when there's someone in the
community who just doesn't interact with
anyone there's like an air of mystery
there yeah yeah
you know what i mean
he's so cool
damn i wonder who he talks to man what
always and then that person is secretly
wishing everyone had reached out
i wish they reached out to me
so many times my god but like your rise
was like fast i remember that when i
found your videos you were getting a few
hundred thousand which is a lot but i
remember you know you you can get up to
like 10 10 million views i remember
whenever you made like an anime video it
just like would not disappear from my
timeline every time
yeah like 4 million
yeah that was crazy i think that was
yeah i think that's a
2018 2019 was i think like my fastest
growing period and it was insane yeah it
was crazy i remember your growth was
just
nuts
yeah
was it like how what kind of growth were
you seeing within that one year because
that was that was that one year when you
started youtube and then you just blew
up immediately yeah oh my god like two
million subs super fast right yeah i
think so in like a year was it like
daunting i think it was like two years
was it yeah it was two years but a
million a year is [ __ ] yeah yeah it
was crazy was it was it daunting just
have like this massive audience just
come to you in like a year yeah
so the way i always describe it which
always like
it like blows my mind because like when
you look at the numbers it's very easy
to like yeah view it as just odds it's a
number yeah but then you have to
consider like do you ever have that
thought every time you pass a stranger
on this on the street you're like this
person why are you laughing because
you're literally describing that meme in
the party where he's like they don't
know i'm gonna reach you
they could have watched my videos
i mean like you you pass a stranger on
the street and
like for a brief moment you
have this understanding that they're an
entire person who has lived an entire
life separate from you
and they have their own set of like
problems and like motivations and like
just all the stuff you don't know about
there's
[Music]
of people a lot of people and emily's
just like let's uh let's characterize
all two million ones of my audience like
what's your back story all right one
down one like can you imagine how many
arcs they've been through in their
entire life it's like a million
yeah it's still daunting
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like now that
you said it like that i'm like oh my god
i'm i'm thinking about it and i'm like
[ __ ] that's that's nice i'm scared now
that's that's a lot of
so much pressure you're putting on
yourself though yeah yeah
i don't know because i'm like now now i
gotta [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm yeah
i just assume my audience is like on the
same level of depth as like a [ __ ]
issac protagonist or something that just
makes it easier to digest npc number two
but like then they don't think about you
that deeply they're like that ain't that
deep they're just like watching
i like this video yeah yeah yeah
literally like i think about how you
watch videos you're not like man i
that's a real person with a you're like
he funny funny stinky
i wonder how old he is right now i
wonder i wonder what he's doing i wonder
what led him up to that moment now
there's i have so many questions now
that i know that you have this like
connection with that yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's it's super dope but like i just
never thought
oh yeah like when you say like that yeah
it is it is very very [ __ ] daunting
um how the [ __ ] did you get past that
yeah i guess like because because i grew
like gradually i guess so i i got to
like it i was like like increments yeah
like warmed up to it you know i gotta
ask because you blew up really quickly
you know normally when you when you
block
you grow really quickly there's normally
like some kind of uh
sometimes your friends can be weird
about it or sometimes people you kind of
you didn't really speak to come and
suddenly start being oh yeah how many
like new facebook
how was the whole process like
i didn't get that many really like
people from my past coming to be like
hey what's up i saw you do you like i
haven't gotten many of that at all
really i think
uh i'll try to make this brief because
it was like a
not so good experience i think the worst
uh that's ever happened
was like there was a girl that i was
good friends with in high school
and then in college like we just didn't
talk because we went to some different
schools and we just like didn't talk it
just happens with your friends uh but i
saw her because she cosplayed and so i
saw her at like a local con
this was like i think when i was during
my first year of youtube right
um
but i saw her at a con and i came up to
her and i was like hey like how are you
it's been so long and i remember she
looked at me and she was like i don't
really have the time for this and i was
like she said that yeah
i'm sorry like i don't know you're busy
my bad i'll just uh okay i'll just go
over there i don't care how busy
you are that is not the excuse you go
for that you don't have the time 10
million i don't have different ways to
say that better yeah and not be an
[ __ ] about it like i remember like i
felt really sad the whole day because i
was like yeah i would be too what the
[ __ ] i saw that you like unfollowed me
on like instagram which
it shouldn't matter but i was like what
did i do i mean combined with that
insult to injury it's like yo what the
[ __ ]
jesus apparently she did have the time
for it because she had the time to like
log into her instagram
unfollow yeah yeah right
fast forward like a year later
um but since the growth was like insane
yeah i have like a bigger following now
and i was walking
through the convention with one of my
friends and suddenly he like oh my god
is that emily and i was like huh and i
looked over and it's that same girl and
i was like i thought we weren't i
thought you didn't like me like what's
going on but no i did it because i was
so sh yeah you should've said i don't
have time for this
the perfect story
[Laughter]
and then and then i realized because she
was like oh my little cousin watches you
i didn't know you had a youtube channel
that's so crazy the lion the witch and
the audacity
yeah and i i got i got kind of annoyed
because at one point she was like
oh yeah like it's so crazy like how you
like talk in your videos like that's not
you i know you and i'm like no you don't
we haven't spoken since high school and
i'm now like 22. you don't know me you
didn't have time for me back then yeah
what makes you think you have time for
me you should be like would you look at
the time i don't have any for you this
is not like a snoop dogg like whoo
it was really bizarre and like since
then i will sometimes like run into her
at cons
and she'll like and she'll be like oh
hey like how are you and i'm like we're
still doing this like
i i don't think until you like give it
like the heart like i don't have time
for your level of like
i think she's just gonna like keep
pretending but i don't want her to be
like oh you got a big head now because
like you got it well no because she
clearly had a big head to begin with
yeah like back then with what she said
to you
yeah i mean i guess but it's too nice i
don't want to emily's just like so
positive i'm just like yeah i would be
taking advantage of this that i think
was like the the best example of like oh
someone's treating me differently yeah
they know i have a following yeah yeah
other than that no what about like
online how did you handle online like
just a massive influx of suddenly like a
lot of people online watching you and
interacting with you oh that was kind of
nerve-wracking of course yeah um
i mean i don't know just but then let's
do it right just deal with that didn't
you blow up while you like your videos
took off while you're still working
though
so here's the other thing um
[Music]
so like i think people have this a lot
of people still have this idea that i am
like this uber wholesome
innocent bun
uh who could never curse i mean i don't
know who would they watch her videos how
could
why would they think maybe because they
only watch your videos yeah your videos
get like 10 million views maybe i always
get like a million yeah yeah so at the
beginning
my videos were like extremely tame
because when i was still when i was
doing youtube during that first year i
was still working with kids
like an after school program at this
like catholic school right right and i'm
not catholic that's just why i was
playing
yeah if you started doing like
so some kids like found out about my
channel and then
the parents know that i have a youtube
channel and so i'm like well i can't i
can't like curse or like say anything
weird on my youtube channel because they
know i work with their kids and i don't
want them to mistrust me
so
for a while i think i think that's where
that kind of started
oh emily is
like wholesome bean yeah
she would never think a lute thought in
her life
and
uh
so then after i quit that job
um then i felt more comfortable to like
oh well now i can like be sort of more
myself when i make videos right
in every video
yeah
and
one of the things that still bothers me
a little bit about like i don't know
having an online presence i i can't
speak for everyone obviously
but i feel like
i feel like with a lot of like female
creators you're put in one of two boxes
you are either a innocent
virginal
wholesome being who must be protected
yep or you're a [ __ ] gobbling [ __ ]
and there's no in between
you're wrong but i think it's somewhat
accurate yeah it's pretty yeah yeah
unfortunately yeah and like in the
viewer's eyes
obviously but i sometimes i feel like a
lot of like female creators feel the
pressure to put themselves in one or two
boxes right right so it's like oh i i
have to be say so i'm 25 and i don't
know what an innuendo is right because
if they knew that i knew they wouldn't
like me anymore yeah or it's like oh no
if i don't i don't know talk about
dicks for the 17th time today people
will forget about me
what are you watching emily
who is
it got to the point where like i would
draw fan art and if i drew like a little
cleavage people would be like i thought
you were i thought you were wholesome
that you were wholesome and i clearly
don't know that that female has a life
of her own you know she's a whole lost
human being you can be wholesome and
draw like a titty it's fine
and like it doesn't bother me that much
it's like if it's kids i get it
yeah yeah yeah but what like weirded me
out is when it's like grown people who
are like surprised that me a fellow
grown person yeah
knows what a dirty joke is yeah yeah